Durante siglos, los economistas han explorado nuestro comportamiento:
cómo tomamos decisiones,
cómo actuamos individualmente y en colectivos,
cómo intercambiamos valor.
Han estudiado las instituciones que facilitan el comercio,
como los sistemas legales,
empresas,
mercados.
Pero hay una nueva institución tecnológica
que cambiará radicalmente cómo intercambiamos valor,
y se llama la cadena de bloques.
Esto es una afirmación muy atrevida,
pero si no se van a quedar con nada más de esta charla
de verdad quiero que recuerden
que aunque la tecnología de esta cadena es relativamente nueva,
también es la continuación de una historia muy humana
Y la historia es esta:
Como humanos, encontramos formas
de disminuir nuestra incertidumbre hacia los demás
para poder intercambiar valor.
Uno de los primeros en verdaderamente explorar la idea
de considerar las instituciones como herramientas económicas
para disminuir nuestra incertidumbre hacia los otros
y ser capaces de comerciar
fue el premio Nobel de economía Douglass North.
Falleció a finales del 2015,
pero North fue el pionero de la denominada "nueva economía institucional".
Y lo que él se refería por instituciones en realidad eran reglas formales
como una constitución,
y restricciones informales, como los sobornos.
Estas instituciones son el motor
que permite que nuestra economía funcione
y esto se observa a lo largo de la historia de la humanidad.
Cuando nuestra economía se sustentaba en la caza-recolección,
solo comerciábamos dentro de nuestro asentamiento.
Había algunas restricciones informales,
pero realizábamos todo nuestro comercio con violencia
o mediante repercusiones sociales.
A medida que la sociedad se hacía más compleja
y las rutas de comercio se ampliaban,
creamos instituciones más formales,
instituciones como bancos,
gobiernos, corporaciones.
Estas instituciones ayudaron a organizar el comercio
mientras aumentaban la incertidumbre y la complejidad
y personalmente controlábamos mucho menos.
Actualmente, con el internet, hemos puesto las instituciones en la red.
Creamos plataformas de mercado como Amazon, eBay, Alibaba,
instituciones más rápidas que actúan como intermediarios
que facilitan nuestra actividad económica.
Según Douglass North,
las instituciones son una herramienta que disminuye la incertidumbre
para que podamos conectar e intercambiar todo tipo de valor en la sociedad.
Y yo creo que ahora está empezando
una evolución más grande y más radical
en la forma en que interactuamos y comerciamos,
porque por primera vez, podemos disminuir la incertidumbre
no solo mediante instituciones políticas y económicas,
como bancos, corporaciones o gobiernos,
sino que podemos hacerlo solo con la tecnología.
Entonces, ¿qué es la cadena de bloques?
La tecnología de la cadena de bloques es una base de datos descentralizada
que almacena un registro de activos y transacciones
en una red peer-to-peer.
Es prácticamente una registro público
de quién posee qué y quién gestiona qué.
Las transacciones se protegen con criptografía,
y el historial de transacciones se guarda en bloques de datos
que más tarde se agrupan y protegen mediante criptografía.
Esto crea un registro inmutable e infalsificable
de todas las transacciones de esta red.
El registro se copia en cada ordenador que utiliza la red.
No es una aplicación.
No es una compañía.
Es algo más parecido a Wikipedia
En Wikipedia podemos verlo todo.
Es una visión compuesta que cambia y se actualiza constantemente.
También podemos rastrear estos cambios con el tiempo en Wikipedia,
y podemos crear wikis,
porque esencialmente, es una infraestructura de datos.
En Wikipedia, las palabras e imágenes y las modificaciones realizadas
se almacenan en una plataforma abierta.
La cadena de bloques,
se puede considerar una infraestructura abierta
que almacena una variedad de activos.
Almacena el historial de custodia,
propiedad y ubicación
de activos como el dinero digital Bitcoin,
otros activos digitales,
como el título de propiedad de una IP.
Puede ser un certificado, un contrato,
objetos físicos,
incluso información personal identificable.
Por supuesto, hay más detalles técnicos en la cadena de bloques,
pero esencialmente, así es como funciona.
Este registro público almacena las transacciones en una red
y las copia para que sea completamente seguro y difícil de falsificar.
Lo cual me lleva a mi argumento
de cómo las cadenas de bloques disminuyen la incertidumbre
y cómo por lo tanto prometen transformar el sistema económico
de forma radical.
Incertidumbre es un término un poco amplio
en economía,
pero voy a centrarme en tres formas
a las que nos enfrentamos en casi todas nuestras transacciones diarias,
que las cadenas de bloques pueden cambiar.
Nos enfrentamos a incertidumbres como no saber con quien lidiamos,
no tener visibilidad en una transacción
y no tener un recurso si las cosas no salen bien.
Así que tomemos el primer ejemplo, no saber con quien lidiamos.
Digamos que quiero comprar un smartphone de segunda mano en eBay.
Lo primero que haría es buscar al vendedor a quien voy a comprar.
¿Es un usuario avanzado?
¿Tiene buenas críticas y votos, o no tiene ningún perfil?
Críticas, votos, vistos buenos:
Todo esto verifica nuestra identidad
que construimos juntos hoy
y usamos para disminuir la incertidumbre sobre con quien tratamos.
Pero el problema es que están muy fragmentadas.
Piensen en cuántos perfiles tienen.
Las cadenas de bloques nos permiten crear una plataforma global abierta
en la que almacenar cualquier verificación sobre cualquier individuo
de cualquier fuente.
Esto nos permite crear una identidad transferible
controlada por los usuarios.
Más que un perfil,
esto significa poder revelar
diferentes atributos de forma selectiva
que ayudan a facilitar el comercio o la interacción,
como que el gobierno le ha expedido un documento de identidad
o que tiene más de 21 años,
revelando la prueba criptográfica
de que esta información existe y está aprobada.
Esta identidad transferible,
tanto en el mundo físico como en el digital,
nos permite establecer todo tipo de comercio
de una forma totalmente nueva.
He hablado de cómo las cadenas de bloques podrían disminuir
la incertidumbre de con quién tratamos.
La segunda incertidumbre bastante habitual
es la falta de transparencia en las interacciones.
Digamos que me van a enviar un smartphone por correo.
Querría tener cierta transparencia.
Querría saber que el producto comprado es el mismo que voy a recibir en el correo
y que hay algún registro de cómo ha llegado.
Este no es solo el caso con dispositivos electrónicos,
sino también con muchos tipos de bienes y datos,
cosas como medicinas, bienes de lujo,
cualquier tipo de datos o producto que no queremos que se falsifique.
El problema en muchas compañías,
especialmente las que producen algo complejo como un smartphone,
es que están gestionando a todos estos comerciantes
en una cadena de suministros horizontal.
Todas estas personas involucradas en la producción
no tienen la misma base de datos.
No utilizan la misma infraestructura,
por lo que se hace muy difícil ver un producto evolucionar transparentemente.
Con la cadena de bloques, podemos crear
una realidad compartida conectando entidades desconfiadas.
Con esto me refiero
a que los nódulos de esta red no necesitan conocerse el uno al otro
o confiar el uno en el otro,
porque ambos tienen la capacidad
de monitorizar y validar la cadena ellos mismos.
Piensen otra vez en Wikipedia.
Es una base de datos compartida,
y aunque tiene múltiples lectores
y múltiples colaboradores al mismo tiempo,
contiene una sola verdad.
Y podemos crear esto con cadenas de bloques.
Podemos crear una base de datos dispersa tan eficiente como un monopolio
sin crear una autoridad central.
Todos estos comerciantes, todo tipo de compañías,
pueden interactuar usando la misma base de datos sin confiar el uno en el otro.
Para los consumidores esto significa mucha más transparencia.
Mientras un objeto físico viaja,
podemos ver su certificado digital o prueba moverse en la cadena de bloques,
añadiendo valor.
En cuanto a visibilidad, esto es un mundo nuevo.
Hemos visto cómo las cadenas de bloques pueden reducir la incertidumbre de identidad
y cómo pueden cambiar lo que nos referimos por transparencia
en comercio complicado y a larga distancia, como en una cadena de suministros.
La última incertidumbre a la que nos enfrentamos a menudo
es una de las más abiertas, y es el incumplimiento.
¿Qué pasa si no me mandan el smartphone?
¿Me van a devolver el dinero?
Las cadenas de bloques nos permiten escribir código,
acuerdos vinculantes,
entre individuos
y más tarde garantizar que el acuerdo se va a cumplir
sin la imposición de una tercera persona.
Si volvemos al ejemplo del smartphone, podríamos pensar en un fideicomiso.
Usted está financiando el teléfono
pero no necesita liberar sus fondos
antes de verificar el cumplimiento de todas las condiciones.
Ya tiene el teléfono.
Esta es una de las formas más interesantes
en las que las cadenas de bloques disminuyen la incertidumbre,
porque en cierto modo
podemos colapsar las instituciones y su ejecución.
Significa que una gran parte de la actividad económica
se puede avalar y automatizar,
y llevar una gran parte de la intervención humana
a las zonas donde la información se mueve del mundo real a la cadena de bloques.
Lo que seguramente dejaría atónito a Douglass North
sobre este uso de la tecnología
es el hecho que la misma cosa que hace que funcione,
la misma cosa que mantiene la seguridad y la verificación de la cadena de bloques,
es nuestra desconfianza mutua.
Estas incertidumbres
no nos frenan,
no nos hacen requerir instituciones
como bancos, gobiernos, compañías,
podemos albergar toda esta incertidumbre colectiva
y utilizarla para colaborar e intercambiar más de forma más rápida y abierta.
No quiero que tengan la impresión
de que la cadena de bloques lo soluciona todo,
incluso cuando lo medios han dicho que acabará con la pobreza mundial,
y solucionará la falsificación de medicamentos
potencialmente salvando la selva.
En verdad, esta tecnología está en desarrollo,
y vamos a tener que presenciar varios experimentos
y posibles fracasos
antes de poder entender todos los casos de uso
para nuestra economía.
Pero hay mucha gente trabajando en ello,
desde instituciones financieras
hasta compañías tecnológicas, empresas emergentes y universidades.
Y una de las razones es que no es solo una evolución económica.
También es una innovación informática.
Las cadenas de bloques nos dan la capacidad tecnológica
de crear un registro de intercambios personales,
intercambios monetarios,,
de todo tipo de activos digitales y físicos,
incluso de nuestros propios atributos,
de una forma totalmente nueva.
En cierto modo,
se convierten en una institución tecnológica
que tiene muchas de las ventajas
de las instituciones tradicionales a las que estamos acostumbrados
pero de una forma descentralizada.
Esto se consigue convirtiendo muchas de nuestras incertidumbres
en certezas.
Así que debemos empezar a prepararnos,
porque estamos a punto de conocer un mundo
donde las instituciones dispersas y autónomas
desempeñarán un papel muy importante.
Gracias.
(Aplauso)
Bruno Giussani: Gracias, Bettina.
Creo haber entendido que está llegando,
tiene un gran potencial,
y es complejo.
¿Cuál es su estimado sobre la tasa de adopción?
Bettina Warburg: Esa es una muy buena pregunta.
Mi laboratorio se centra
en empezar con empresas y el gobierno,
porque la cadena de bloques es una tecnología compleja.
¿Cuántos de ustedes entienden cómo funciona el internet?
Sin embargo, lo usan a diario,
creo que estamos ante la misma idea de John Sculley
de que la tecnología debería ser o invisible o bella,
y la cadena de bloques no es exactamente ninguna de las dos todavía,
así que es más apropiada para usuarios pioneros
que la entienden y pueden jugar con ella
o para encontrar los casos donde utilizarla
como rastrear identidades o activos o contratos inteligentes
que pueden usarse a nivel de una empresa o gobierno.
BG: Gracias. Gracias por venir a TED.
BW: Gracias.
(Aplauso)